[Music]
hey guys welcome to today
i'm off to jenna's house i've got maddie
we're gonna be going to the dog park and
then heading to the airport we're
heading home to pittsburgh for easter
and easter is one of my favorite
holidays
so i'm excited to go home and spend it
with my family but first starbucks
dog park airport
he knows where we're going i'm listening
to royalty-free music
this is great i can let it play and not
get in trouble
is that is that ed oh my goodness
oh somebody's excited
over it hi here's your birthday card oh
my gosh i got it and lost it and then
found it again
this is exciting thank you
happy birthday to myself man let's go
get a coffee come on baby
let's go this way now you do it
oh gosh let me get let me hold your
coffee maddie
ed just picked up your poop say say
thank you very much did a bad job
so i uh was eating my sandwich and
maddie just took a crap i was like ed
what do we do
you're you were a poodle you're not
vicious ed picked up the poop for me so
because i was eating thank you
we're going to the dog park now let's go
[Music]
maddie
oh my goodness daddy i'm gonna go see
jenna
you wanna go see jenna let's go see
jenna okay
nope no return flight home yet and uh
that's pretty much the status of where
you guys are going to be i mean
i think ed and i are trying to figure
out fun things to do while you guys are
gone what boys easter
beauty boy easter party sunday you guys
can go on an egg hunt
lots of eggs i'll have some eggs
somewhere we
have a parking lot easter egg hunt that
sounds fun
i'm so glad we're playing southwest so
that i will get re-accommodated
hey everyone i'm back home in
pennsylvania here for the easter holiday
i love easter it's like my favorite
holiday oh god i haven't even made it on
the hike
i'm gonna fall wow someone is very
excited to be here
[Music]
so we've been extremely deceived we
thought we were taking just a quick
little walk get a nice little
sightseeing
in fly the drone we've been walking for
well it's not that far but it feels far
and maddie is not a very good walker at
all where'd he go you lost him
yeah no i was like bri he's really hard
to walk she's like i can take him i can
do it i'm like all right good luck
i almost fell right on my face
so we're here i was so excited to fly my
drone and this
we could not be any closer with their
power lines just
look right here so no drone
you know bo
maddie what happened here
you know i think it's fine we'll just uh
yep just being a dog he's gonna sit on
me now
[Music]
hi i messed up my name what did you do
well i threw a bomb i wasn't supposed to
throw a bomb
happy easter we're on our way to easter
brunch and jenna and i are playing
switch bride's driving us and bree is
riding shotgun
she loves nintendo
and video games bree's pretty much
probably the biggest
non-fan of video games that i've ever
met oh
it's true though she likes uh what was
that iphone game
i don't like anything he doesn't like to
have fun oh
free no fun you're in trouble
i'm sorry trouble somebody's in trouble
my goodness for the fun is not nintendo
trust me i don't know how i'm related to
that demon either
she's a devil a devil and a jumpsuit
[Music]
summer's sipping
springtime sorry
[Music]
we just got back home from easter lunch
the dogs are going absolutely crazy but
i'm going to take my drone out because
we're going to be doing our egg hunt
very very
shortly and i want to see if i can see
where the golden egg is before we
actually get outside i need to survey
the land
see if i can find that egg and get it
before anybody else does
[Music]
oh
you get like three but i got the gold
big that's good
let's see how many i got well let's
explain why because i said hold on let
me get my drone in position and everyone
just took off
running let's see how many eggs i got
this year
eleven really twelve
thirteen whoa didn't you send the drone
up previously to see where they all were
no yeah you did hey hey how many eggs
did you get
a lot how many like 50.
more than 13 yes brian said he got more
than 13. yeah you got a lot oh he's a
cheater
how many did you get count them i got
13.
13 eggs a shootout
brian's eggs mike brian you're a liar he
didn't actually he didn't tell me a
number
i have to be quiet because the pen's
game is on and and i'll get in trouble
[Music]
you